so this video is about the short answer
section on the ap u.s history exam
so this is a real practice problem from
the ap exam and i'd like to go through
it step by step with you to give you an
idea of how to approach these problems
really well so each of the short answer
problems is three questions long and
they all discuss
one
facet of american history and so your
job in these questions is not to try to
write an essay but merely to just answer
a b and c which will be related to each
other and you have about the front of
one blue book page to do this so really
no more than 200 words
and what's great about these is that
there are many right answers right
they're asking you to display your
knowledge about a topic in the past but
what parts of that knowledge you display
is up to you so that means you can
really play to your strengths bring up
the thing that you know you don't have
to worry about knowing everything just
enough to answer a few questions so
let's read this question and we're going
to read it really carefully which you'll
see is important for a number of reasons
so answer a b and c a
briefly explain one example of how
contact between native americans and
europeans brought changes to native
american societies in the period
1492-1700
now this is really important
making sure that you know the date range
that you're being asked to write about
is really key to giving a good answer
because we could talk about native
american history in american society
really right up to the present so 1700
is our end date
b briefly explain a second example of
how contact between native americans and
europeans brought changes to native
american societies in the same period
and c briefly explain one example of how
native american societies resisted
change brought by contact with europeans
in the same period all right so
basically what we're being asked here is
to give two examples of change
and one example of resistance to that
change
now the way i see it we have one really
important stricture like i mentioned
already which is that we can only talk
about the period in between
european contact and the year 1700 so
that means a lot of things that you
might want to be talking about from the
1800s and 1900s you can't hear because
you won't get credit for it so we're
talking about the period long before the
american revolution
long before even the french and indian
war seven years war so this is really
early contact but the question actually
doesn't give any strictures about
societies
so we could talk about native americans
in north america at large we could talk
about native americans
in jamestown or we could talk about
native americans in mexico
we could talk about native americans and
the french in the northwest territories
so our geography is really broad here
it's our timeline that's relatively
short
so let's brainstorm what we could talk
about for answers a or b
well we could mention i think an
excellent example would be disease
right
native americans experienced an epidemic
of disease related to pathogens brought
over by europeans so you could talk
about how disease really reshaped
society particularly there were
morning wars
in the northeast where native americans
would raid new england's settlements
trying to find replacements for the
people who had died in disease you could
also talk about trade um
and uh for example horses might be a
good example of this the spanish brought
horses to the new world which completely
changed the form of transportation and
wealth for a lot of native american
societies on the great plains
what else could we talk about well we
could also mention labor
the spanish tried to implement a system
of encomienda
labor which would grant land to the
spanish for native americans to labor
upon in a system of slavery you might
also talk about gender roles
and
intermarriage
between
native americans and
europeans
which
changed racial patterns and created
new racial caste systems and also
changed the way that women were often
viewed in native american societies
often resulting in them having less
power than they did before the europeans
arrived when you're thinking about how
to answer these types of questions one
of the most useful things you can do is
think about
race
class
and gender
these are things that historians think
about all the time and what they mean by
these things is to say how does a
certain issue affect say white people
differently than it might affect black
people
or native american people differently
than it might affect europeans or does
this affect rich people
more than it affects poor people
and that might also include people who
own
a factory for example
versus the people who
work in a factory or labor in a factory
and lastly you might think about whether
something affects men or women
differently
or people of different gender
expressions or sexualities
so if you're stuck on what to write take
some time to think about how a certain
event may have affected anyone in these
three groups differently than another
group
all right so we answered the first two
questions and you'll see that any one of
these
is a perfectly appropriate answer and
you only have to talk about one for each
and for each of these i would really
only just write one sentence
make sure that that sentence gets at the
heart of what it is that you're trying
to say for example don't just write
disease
but rather write a sentence that says
the introduction of pathogens brought
from the old world to the new affected
native american societies by drastically
reducing their populations and their
settlement patterns all right let's
pause here for now and in the next video
we'll tackle part c